bonjour alexis bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france alors
anne hidalgo on vient de le voir à tenir
un meeting à perpignan après cette
déclaration sur la primaire populaire
elle continue sa campagne mais est ce
qu'elle peut trouver une dynamique à
présent ça me paraît extrêmement
compliqué anne hidalgo elle a choisi de
se retirer en quelque sorte en appelant
à cette primaire 1 parce qu'elle
plafonne dans les sondages elle voit que
la dynamique n'est pas là elle a du mal
à convaincre aussi sur le programme donc
elle a décidé par une pirouette de
proposer à tous les candidats de douche
de se réunir derrière l'idée d'une
primaire populaire première populaire
qui existent avant même les déclarations
de candidatures des uns et des autres
mais qui était en fond d'écran va dire
de cette campagne de gauche avec en
ligne de mire une potentielle
candidature de christiane taubira qui
serait un peu la figure qui sauverait la
gauche enfin cette gauche de
gouvernement le parti socialiste on va
dire que le problème d'anne hidalgo
c'est le parti socialiste et le bilan de
ce parti socialiste c'est à dire les
trahisons de françois hollande de mon
ennemi c'est la finance à la loi travail
un quinquennat qui a été mal vu par les
électeurs de gauche justement vu comme
une trahison et puis ce discours à
perpignan où finalement elle dit je vais
sanctuariser la retraite à 62 ans c'est
une mesure de nicolas sarkozy est une
mesure d'un président de droite donc ou
essaient de gauche cette gauche sociale
démocrate comme elle le dit bien elle
est en train d'être un peu fayot cité
par la gauche écolo celle de yannick
jadot qui est un peu plus haut dans les
sondages pas très haut non plus il était
en campagne également meeting samedi
mais pour anne hidalgo tout le problème
aujourd'hui c'est de se retirer sans le
dire et de se retirer par le haut on a
vu aussi arnaud montebourg d'ailleurs ça
fait réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
appelaient au téléphone
pour un rassemblement pour une
candidature unique là encore est ce que
c'est une chance d'unifier la gauche ou
si une peine perdue oui alors arnaud
montebourg
c'est particulier parce que il part il
disparaît il revient parce que la
campagne présidentielle et là il se dit
tiens pourquoi pas moi allons-y il
plafonne à 1 2 % dans les sondages il
n'a quasiment aucune chance de lever
suffisamment d'argent pour faire
campagne ou d'avoir 500 signatures donc
lui aussi dans une logique de retirer sa
candidature alors il ne dit pas ça comme
ça il dit qu il offre sa candidature à
qui en veut d'une certaine façon et puis
ils disent je ne me retire pas non non
ce que je veux c'est aussi poussé à
l'unité mais pourquoi lui qui représente
1 2% qui vient aussi du parti socialiste
se met en scène avec son téléphone pour
appeler chaque candidat qui ne répond
pas on voit l'échec d'anne hidalgo dans
sa proposition de primaire on voit
l'échec d'arnaud montebourg dans sa
tentative un d'unité des partis de
gauche c'est l'échec du parti socialiste
que disait ségolène royal et de manière
très juste que ce soir de montebourg
comme anne hidalgo il n'y a pas à
tergiverser ils sont loin derrière donc
ils doivent se mettre derrière les
candidats qui ont le plus de chances de
gagner sans essayer de faire une
pirouette ou d'essayer de faire perdre
ses candidats parce que là on a affaire
finalement à laax des perdants qui
décide avant tout le monde avant même
les électeurs avant même les militants
que la gauche a d'emblée perdu cette
élection c'est faux c'est pas du tout ce
que je pense yannick jadot ou jean luc
mélenchon l'ajustement yannick jadot
jean luc mélenchon nos vents de dans les
sondages même si loin derrière les
candidats de droite ne souhaite pas de
primaires alors quels scénarios
possibles oui alors c'est sûr que quand
on regarde les sondages les deux
candidats de gauche qui se démarquent
yannick jadot et jean luc mélenchon sont
loin des 15 % des 10 7% et c'est qu'on a
pu voir ces derniers jours pour valérie
pécresse par exemple mais néanmoins ni
l'un ni l'autre ne souhaite rentrer dans
une logique de primaire ils avancent
leurs cartes sur la campagne
il vous avez quand même jean luc
mélenchon qui se présente pour la
troisième fois cette élection
présidentielle avec un programme
l'avenir en commun qu'ils aient
travaillé depuis des années des
militants une organisation donc de
campagnes yannick jadot qui est un parti
e élevé qui a fait une primaire alors
certes ya pas eu de bulle médiatique 1
avec sandrine rousseau qui reste quand
même une figure importante maintenant
dans le l'échiquier écolo et puis des
soubresauts de campagne la férule oh
bien sûr qu'il ya qui a posé quelques
soucis puisque matthieu orphelin était
dégagée de son poste de porte parole
donc là aussi sur yannick jadot l'envi
de continuer à un rythme particulier
parce que un sondage du jour dans le
parisien aujourd'hui en france dit que
les français en fait n'arrive pas à
comprendre même voir cette campagne de
nelly jadot est invisible côté mélenchon
il fait tout pour et visible sur les
réseaux sociaux le grand meeting en même
temps que zemmour c'était il ya une
semaine de cela voilà donc on a deux
formations politiques qui essaient de
faire campagne de manière assez
différente mais qui représente
aujourd'hui la gauche social-démocrate
avec l'écologie et puis la gauche
anticapitaliste d'une certaine façon
avec la france a soumises et puis un
ancien ministre socialiste qui s'est
exprimé hier également dans les colonnes
de dans les colonnes du jvc manuel valls
et pour lui il parle d'une gauche qui
meurent chaque jour un peu plus oui
alors manuel valls et tout ce qui fait
je pense que la gauche on est là les
électeurs de gauche d'ailleurs lui en
veulent il est quand même celui qui
quitte la france en disant bon ben je
vais tenter ma chance à barcelone il
fait une alliance avec des partis
d'extrême droite là bas ici lors de la
campagne des régionales contre une
alliance de gauche il appelle à voter
valérie pécresse la candidate de droite
donc qui est il aujourd'hui pour un se
dire de gauche et deux donner des leçons
à la gauche je crois que manuel valls il
est symptomatique de ce malaise
politique c'est à dire la survivance
d'un parti zombies qui est le parti
socialiste qui aujourd'hui bien sûr à
des élues en régions dans les
territoires dans les villes mais au
niveau national ce parti un problème
d'image ce n'est pas en essayant de
défendre une droite républicaine
les valses east il faut le rappeler sont
nombreux dans l'entourage d'anne hidalgo
donc cet axe là on le voit il n'imprime
pas auprès des électeurs de gauche il ne
fonctionne pas il faut soit se
réinventer avec les maquereaux nist dans
la maison commune soit trouver autre
chose mais
manuel valls doit arrêter la politique
d'une certaine façon personne dans ce
pays merci beaucoup alexis poulain
l'édito politique d'alexis poule à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
tous les lundis matin dans la matinale
de france